busy
yes
hey
shh keep it down i've always heard about
the wide range of ingredients you can
no i'm a chef a chef on a mc my name is
xiangling
i'm from hello my piemon why are you
what an exotic creature is it edible
no for the last time you seem like good
friends
i have a good friend too called goba
isn't that the name of both the snack
and anyway there's lots of game around
here that would be amazing i can't catch
anything to say
so don't be like that oh you had me a
tasty snack
don't worry i don't care great then i'll
huh
bet you can't keep up with me
[Music]
bet you can't keep up with me
huh
wowie this is great some of it
you have finally come around to my food
preferences oh
sorry as promised are we your food oh
gosh this is delicious can you tell us
how to make
sure the only thing is i have i got it
this seems pretty hard to make come on
we can fry on a
sweet flowers will do for sugar as for
salt
i just can't give me a second while i
get everything ready
hey what
this is the boar's natural habit we
hunters know better than to kill the
chick oh
the freshest best quality meat comes
from free-range boars
that grow up in the environment nature
intended for them it would be a
major blow to gastronomy i'm sorry
as our leader he always stresses the i
made a mistake
thanks guys okay draft oughta be in
spring